so a judge rules that the trump campaign  non-disclosure agreement the nda  is invalid the story behind this  particular case  is incredible it's been going on for  years but jessica denson  most recently has filed a class-action  lawsuit to invalidate  the trump campaign's nda that was  preventing her from disclosing  what she saw and learned as a member of  the trump campaign  so at the moment at least one federal  court has said that her particular nda  is non-enforceable but she's filed this  as a class action and it appears  that she and her lawyers intend to move  forward and invalidate all of the ndas  with respect to the people that worked  for the trump campaign so this is  not the last that we have heard of this  particular lawsuit it may eventually go  up to the court of appeals but for the  time being it doesn't look good for the  trump campaign  so we'll see them in court